it's great to welcome to the program
today daniel goldman who is of course
well known for his writings on emotional
intelligence
on meditation a number of other topics
that that are very interesting to me
it's great to have you on today thanks
david pleasure to be here
so maybe maybe just to start the
conversation we're hopefully
starting to get to the beginning of the
end or the
the end of the middle or some somewhere
closer to where life will
in some ways return to normal vis-a-vis
the pandemic but one of the things i've
been talking with many people about
um are kind of speculating about what
the longer-term effects might be
of this pandemic i think certainly some
degree of
of uh the feeling that the world is a
hostile place which may connect to some
agoraphobia for many people
uh people may be realizing that the
risks
that they were taking before were bigger
than maybe they acknowledged and
changing behavior
going forward it's just some ideas how
are you conceiving of
this kind of exit process and what the
impacts may be emotionally
psychologically
well i see two upsides
coming at some point one is that
everybody's been under tremendous stress
because of the lockdown
particularly working parents i mean how
do you work from home and manage
kids running in and out of your zoom you
know and
you know life goes on and that just is
um
raises the stress level to a point where
people may be feeling emotionally
exhausted
uh and that hopefully will be relieved
when
things ease up the second is a kind of
disconnect we haven't been able to see
our friends you know hanging out in the
way we usually do
and zoom or or skype but you know these
video
conferencing ways of meeting people
do something a little weird to the
social circuitry of the brain
and that is i can't look you in the eye
at the same time i see your face
if you're right you're either looking at
the camera if you look at the camera it
looks like you're looking at me but then
you're not really looking at where you
see me on your screen yeah exactly
so the the disconnect is that there's no
eye contact anymore
at least on screen and we'll be able to
have that again what a relief
to the extent we can see people and
you're right people still have to be
safe i'm double vaccinated and we just
saw some friends outside
still with masks you know i'm of an age
where i might be vulnerable
i've got to be very careful and people
need to be careful too not
just for themselves but for other people
they love and contact regularly
but then the big unanswered question is
the one you raise
what will be the long-term consequences
of having not been able to see people as
usual
i think on children and teenagers
because the social emotional circuitry
of the brain
is the last part of the brain to become
anatomically mature
it doesn't get set in place until the
mid-20s
and at every stage children and teens
need something there's what's called the
five to seven shift
when kids prefrontal uh cortex comes
online and circuitry that allows them to
just say no to emotional impulse gets
stronger and stronger
but then as they develop they need to be
with other kids
the kids learn an immense amount
emotionally and socially
from their peers and all of a sudden
it's gone
and we don't know what the consequences
would be i tend to be an optimist i tend
to think
well you know kids are really adept
at remedial learning and i hope that
turns out to be true we just don't know
yeah from from a strictly mathematical
standpoint
a 30 year old being home for a year and
a 60 year old being home for a year as a
proportion of their lives
is very different than someone that was
six
and from six to seven that's you know
that's more than fifteen percent of
their lives
is that kind of relative uh comparison
important in thinking about who might
suffer the biggest impact in a sense
perhaps what that mathematics does not
factor in is the rate at which children
might be able to make
up for what they didn't get and you know
you see this
children are children's brains are
remarkably plastic that way
so we have a model of uh
the the family unit two parents you know
and a kid or kids
as being essential but actually the
human brain was designed for all kinds
of tragedies
maybe your parents get killed uh you
know maybe
someone else takes care of you you can
learn the same things from the caretaker
that you would have
from your parent that's the way the
brain is designed so
we'll see uh how adept
kids are at undoing what what has been
done to them
one of the things i've been noticing
myself is now is someone who's
double vaccinated and i'm following all
the cdc guidelines which now include
that
unless you're in a big crowd outdoors
you don't have to wear a mask president
joe biden telling us this the cdc
telling us this last year
but yet i still find myself thinking
even though i know i'm following all the
guidelines when someone else goes by
without a mask
there's a second where my mind does
something where i say whoa hold on this
is this is dangerous in some way
but then i remember hold on a second at
the worst case
one out of a thousand cases were being
transmitted outdoors the person's 20
feet away
i've been conditioned in a sense to
perceive danger maybe where there is not
is that something that you expect will
persist for some time
well david you're you're very um
probabilistically oriented yes
and that's a kind of a cognitive control
you're reframing the situation i
completely agree
and not many people can do that lots of
people just react
viscerally they don't have the cognitive
wherewithal to
to say well it's one in a thousand and
it's outdoors and so on
so um i think people will be
reacting now and for some time from
their emotional centers rather
rationally and cognitively you've been
uh doing more and more work
or at least i've been seeing more and
more of your work related to meditation
of late
and i've been studying with great
interest some of the
research that is done into the effects
of meditation
on the brain and there are all sorts of
different opinions about is the effect
overstated or understated or do we not
yet really know
whether in the context of the pandemic
or not can you talk a little bit about
your focus on on meditation and and why
you think it's an important thing for
in particular now well i think it's a
natural next step from emotional
intelligence you know emotional
intelligence says
and my model has four parts there's
self-awareness
and then using that awareness to manage
your disturbing emotions well and
martial positive ones well it turns out
that meditation
is a very good tool for doing that it is
an exercise in self-awareness
and i just did a book with richard
davidson who's a neuroscientist at
the university of wisconsin and we
looked at the very best studies and we
found from the beginning
people tend to be more calm and more
clear if they meditate and there's a
dose response
effect so that the longer you do it the
more hours you put in
the more this seems to happen long-term
meditators are
triggered less often
less severely and recover more quickly
we found
from the data and very high you know
olympic level meditators are a whole
other thing
and it turns out that if you do an
exercise
that increases warm-heartedness
compassion or caring
you become more compassionate caring
it's kind of a no-brainer but it turns
out that the part of
the brain actually that
where those circuits reside become
stronger and that
behaviorally you're more likely to help
someone in need you're more generous
and so on so meditation seems to work
and the second part of emotional
intelligence
is empathy and i'm i'm
rethinking emotional intelligence now uh
if i can i mention my podcast please of
course yeah it's available
i just started a podcast called first
person singular
where some of my newest thinking is
shared with people and one of the ways
i'm rethinking it
is in terms of what is empathy i know
it's cognitive
i know it's emotional but it also is
empathic concern
which means you care about the other
person not just you know how they think
you know how they feel
but you want what's best for them it's
like a parent's love for a child
and i think this leads to compassion or
to
that whole uh unfolding of
warm-heartedness
yeah i mean what's very interesting to
me about this and i don't want to make
everything political and i'm glad not to
but one of the things that i've been
i've been reading quite a bit about is
that on well-designed
sort of assessments of the level of
empathy and compassion that are
triggered in people when they are told a
particular story or see a particular
image
it can very accurately predict
one's political leanings on a sort of
general conservative
liberal uh spectrum as we might imagine
it in the united states applies to
democrats and republicans and then
the next question sort of becomes how
much of this is nature how much is
nurture how much is
the environment you grew up around and
kind of what your parents modeled for
you versus is there something in the
brain and different people have
different opinions
in theory at least this could be very
relevant from a policy standpoint could
it not
you know it it reminds me of some data i
saw
years ago when i was a science
journalist at the new york times
and it it was a behavioral genetic study
of different uh behavioral variables one
of which was conservatism
which turned out to have a very high
heritability
which suggests that part of this may be
in our inherited circuitry
the tendency to want things to be safe
to want things to be
the same and then translate that into a
political orientation
and then uh the policy question becomes
a very interesting one
but not one i'm an expert on so i'm
going to finesse it david
well no but i guess i mean from this
from the standpoint that is more
more relevant to your work there is that
question of when we say heritability
is it genetically heritable versus is it
culturally heritable my
instinct would be that and that while
there may be
a genetic heritability if you take a
group of kids that's statistically more
likely to be republicans from you know
utah or something like that
but you raise them in liberal
massachusetts families my instinct is
that the upbringing
will have a significant impact even on
whatever genetic heritability is there i
don't know i'm thinking out loud
yeah david i agree with you it's always
nurture as well as nature
and how kids are brought up or the
culture you're
socialized into has a great impact on
how you behave
even given a you know xyz
inherited tendency so i
i'm with you i think it would matter but
we don't know
do you um do do you take an evolutionary
perspective at all
on human empathy uh because i've read
a lot one way or the other about the the
evolutionary advantage
of empathy uh and there are there's the
position that it's sort of vestigial
that
that an advantage that was at one point
relevant may no longer be today
i don't know is that something you think
about
well i i tend to take an evolutionary
perspective
and uh from my from that point of view
uh empathy has a real upside because
when humans started living in groups and
cooperating
which takes empathy uh you know teamwork
basically
made humans uh the species that was a
standout
regrettably uh evolution did not foresee
the predicament we're in
now where uh our economics the everyday
things we buy and use are degrading the
the ecosystem we depend on to survive
and i think that will become a more more
compelling
reality for younger generations as time
goes on
i think it will reverberate back into
the
business world and that
corporations companies will be find it
is in their best interest to do things
in a better way for the environment
because they want to keep market share
and people will care
do you think that there's or is there a
particular
uh lens that you think is a valuable
lens
to think about the issues you work on
that's essentially missing right now
from the national conversation in other
words if you are
sort of going to uh the typical news
sources
and informed by what people see on
social media some
some aspect of thinking about the
society in which we now live
that's not really getting the attention
it deserves that you think would be a
great thing
if it did i call it radical transparency
and i mean ecological transparency
uh and i actually just did a podcast on
this
it's an idea who i think whose time has
come basically
right now we have full transparency
about the cost of products
we have zero transparency about the
ecological impacts of products
so if you were to buy a new mic or a new
shirt ideally
and the methodology for this exists you
could
know the full environmental impact of
that
over its full life cycle and you would
know that a point of purchase
this this is the ideal and
it might happen one day and i think it
may be expedited by younger generations
the reason being
the uh coming climate crisis
which is being the engine of which
has been our economic system let's see
if we can
do an example of that so we know that a
lot of clothing is now really cheap
and we intuitively know that part of the
reason it's inexpensive
is it's produced uh in countries with
very that pay very low wages and um
that is why we are able to get a shirt
for seven dollars that
maybe would otherwise cost thirty
dollars the idea of the transparency
you're talking about would be
when you see the seven dollar price tag
of the
sri lankan made shirt it might have
something there that says
the full product life cycle makes this
really
a forty dollar shirt now i as the buyer
may not
be out of pocket for the additional
thirty three dollars
but it would at least be available to me
to know that that cost
is part of this purchase and it may be
more expensive
than the 30 us-made shirt i mean in
theory to come up with just an example
of what you mean
yeah so i would i think that the
ecological transparency would probably
be more powerful when you're choosing
between a seven dollar and a ten dollar
shirt
and you find out that the uh ten dollar
shirt is made with alternative energy
and is made with cotton which
is not grown in a place where water is
super scarce and
right it's driving people away because
of that
and the factory that it was made in
actually pays a decent wage rather than
starvation wage and you may think well
you know i'm gonna do some good
with that extra three bucks and i'm
gonna buy the ten dollar shirt rather
than the seven dollar shirt
and i think that will start to that
transparency would shift market share
so that the guy who's making the seven
dollar shirt can say
hey why aren't people buying my shirts
and find out and say okay well i'm going
to do this and this and this
and then get certified by an independent
body
that he's improved and then he's now
again competitive with the 10
shirt that's interesting i mean i think
you're right that
the comparison is much easier the
decision is much easier when it's 7
versus 10
but maybe that's some of the difficulty
as well because i don't
you know i don't know enough about the
production of shirts to know this but
it's conceivable that the difference
would be far bigger and so
the the financial impact on an
individual
might be less trivial than maybe seven
to ten dollars might be
i actually think that uh in in the
actual competitive arena of companies
yeah who are looking at their supply
chain how they extract
how they manufacture they would do
incremental changes
and so you know the two seven dollar
shirts would say hey my sub dollar shirt
doesn't isn't going to threaten the the
uh climate
that guys is right in other words that's
more likely
to be the arena and look you know
another
interesting example is our cell phones
everybody's got one these days
and who knew that they all
have rare earths as they're called some
of which are mined in places that have
slave labor
yes yes well darn you know what are you
going to do about that
if we had transparency about that i
think that that
could change yeah there's a lot of ways
in which transparency and it's really
bizarre because
one of the fundamental principles of the
free market economy is transparency
and and there is zero transparency
yeah yeah i think you know the the
electric car
example is an interesting one because i
think this is being improved upon
but the footprint of making the
batteries
is not insignificant and then what you
do with the batteries after the fact
is i think we're closer to solving that
but the disposal is also significant
and that is is completely opaque i think
to most
uh most electric car buyers and plastics
is the same
if you were to do a life cycle
assessment of plastic
and that's what this method is called it
would look like plastic
bags are better than brown paper bags
but that's because the
life cycle assessment does not include
end of life right
and plastics as we now are finding out
are in us
and fish and birds and everything else
uh and it's a huge problem that we had
not realized so
anyway you asked what's missing and i
think that's what's missing
that's a great example yeah that's a
that's a beautiful note to uh
to to end on we've been speaking with
daniel goldman we will link to
the podcast as well as some some of his
books
daniel such a pleasure having you on i
so appreciate your time
david it's a real pleasure thank you
very much